Now let's begin the discussion on sexual attraction and the qualities we look
for in potential sexual partners. Now according to the sexual strategy theory,
men and women approach relationships differently. And perhaps you can reflect
upon this in some of your own relationships experiences. In terms of how you
may have approached a relationship differently than your partner. We see that
in almost all societies, people engage in one night stands, or what we like to
call, short term meetings. We also have long term meetings, which include
marriage or extended companionship. So our committed long term relationships
often result in marriage. In one study conducted in the United States, they
found that 86% of women by the age of 40 and 81% of men by the age of 40 will
marry. If you recall from our earlier lesson on development, we had a question
on the forums about the age your parents got married. And we discuss the change
across generations, in regards to the age people marry. Now this is just one
study in the United States. But long term relationships occur in most cultures.
They may do so at different times or ages, and for different reasons. For
example in some cultures marriages are arranged, so the individuals have no say
in the matter. But in other cultures people often marry for love, that is they
fall in love with one another and then they decide to spend the rest of their
lives together.